é eu não acredito no conhecimento eu
adoto o conhecimento é que até o momento
se apresenta melhor ferramenta para o
meu trabalho e se amanhã chegar um novo
eu posso abandonar esse aqui rapidamente
o que eu não acredito nele né a crença é
um ato de fé e conhecimento não exige um
ato de fé e foi por isso que comecei a
estudar a questão da relação da escola
com a família e se o tema sim da nossa
conversa aqui hoje é um tema muito
carinhoso pra mim eu ter muito cuidado
é eu comecei a ouvir é depois que meus
filhos já estavam no ensino fundamental
é a história de que a parceria escola
família era muito importante era boa
os pais precisavam ir para as escolas e
eu como mãe não como profissional me
perguntar mas por que será que eu tenho
aqui na escola dos meus filhos e para
mim era um estranhamento absoluto porque
quando criança eu nasci em 1950
nunca meus pais foram na minha escola
nunca jamais passou pela cabeça deles ir
até lá o a cabeça da escola de convidar
os pais para e até o seu espaço
então quantas escolas que meus filhos
freqüentavam começaram a convidar os
pais para irem até lá fiquei me
perguntando mas porque pra que eu fui
durante toda a infância e adolescência
dos meus filhos aquilo que as escolas
adoram chamar de mãe ausente
eu não ia nem uma reunião que a escola
convocava porque olhava pauta me
interessava me interessar basta
interessava nem um pouco saber o que o
terceiro ano 4º ano e até como eater
estava interessada em como aquela escola
queria educar na formação de atitudes de
virtudes de valores mas a escola já não
estava mais interessada disso
aliás nunca esteja e aos poucos eu fui
me interessando profissionalmente por
esse tema e comecei a entender que aqui
em nosso país no brasil a gente tem uma
convicção de que a parceria escola
família é importante quando a gente
começa a questionar suas convicções
inclusive do lado dos educadores formais
nem os professores às escolas
a gente começa a perceber que não é uma
base sólida para essa afirmação a
relação à parceria boa né
algumas bases que não são assim tão
sólidas fundamentam essa afirmação
uma delas é quando a família se envolve
com a vida escolar do seu filho ele
produz mais
ele tira boas notas
isso me implica muito nem eu tenho uma
antipatia por essa informação porque nós
vamos dividir as crianças em dois tipos
de crianças aquelas que têm só tinha
aquelas que não tens as crianças que têm
santis são aquelas que nasceram em
famílias que por diversos motivos
diferentes quem o dom tem a paciência é
tem condição de sentar com a criança
acompanhar passo a passo a vida escolar
dela e também não vejo mérito algum
gente uma criança que tem a ajuda dos
pais e bem pra escola
eu acho que o desafio à lei bem na
escola sozinha ela aprender bastante
sozinha não precisa dessa colaboração de
quem já passou pela escola é outra vez
recentemente houve uma escola oferecendo
curso de matemática dos pais do que
matemática que eles aprenderam diferente
daquela que eles ensinam então os pais o
rio lá fazer o curso de matemática poder
em casa ajudar os filhos a isso é
loucura né
uma loucura que nós vivemos num mundo
que está em transição e que nesse
período de transição o que acontece
os papéis ficam confusos
e hoje quando a gente pensa na educação
a gente se pergunta é o que cabe à
escola o que cabe à família
eu frequento redes sociais e vira e mexe
eu vejo lá alguns postes é que me irrita
profundamente mas eu vejo é a escola
cabe incluir ainda a família cabe educar
como se fosse possível né educassem
instruirá instruíssem educar não é
possível
esses conceitos são inseparáveis
mas isso mostra apenas a nossa confusão
né
é a gente é neste mundo em transição
encontramos as chamadas novas famílias e
suas famílias mudaram muito e quando eu
penso nessas mudanças e nem penso muito
no desenho das famílias que hoje nós
temos muitas configurações
algumas inclusive desconhecidas né nós
ainda não terminamos as mudanças que
estão ocorrendo ea gente pensa na escola
as novas famílias ea velha escola como a
gente acabou de ouvir aqui né
é como é que a gente pode fazer
acontecer alguma coisa para essas
crianças que nascem nesse mundo fruto
dessa relação e lou que se de que
ninguém sabe direito o que deve fazer
com essa criança e do fim como nós
adultos
estamos absolutamente radicalmente
afetados pela ideologia da juventude
eu quero ser jovem a qualquer custo até
o dia que eu morrer não importa unidade
isso faz com que a gente se dirija ao
nosso olhar no espelho para o umbigo
breve o que for pra mim e eu esqueça um
pouco né que às vezes têm mais novos que
dependem de mim tenham filhos ou não mas
principalmente quando têm filhos quem eu
alunos ou não mas principalmente quando
eu sei
a questão que a gente precisa pensar
nós vamos conseguir é redefinir os
papéis educacionais formal da escola
informal da família rapidamente não
vamos
não vamos porque esse é um processo
lento né
mudam primeiro aqui os conceitos e
depois os comportamentos e atitudes e
nós ainda estamos brigando com conceitos
aqui eu ainda hoje ou sul
as escolas chamarem os pais de pais
ausentes mas é família disfuncional que
é isso é uma falta de respeito mútuo
entre família escola que não leva a isso
que todo mundo gosta de dizer que leva
que é uma boa parceria não é né não uma
boa parceria uma boa relação entre
escola família seria uma relação justa
respeitosa solidária e democrática
esse tipo de relação da escola com a
família poderia inovar na educação
podia produzir uma nova educação né
mas a gente não sabe direito como é que
estabelecemos uma relação justa como
escola quando digo escola gente eu digo
no sentido da imagem da escola não é uma
escola em especial né
as nossas escolas são muito parecidas
entre si por isso eu posso falar a
escola no singular é como é que eu posso
estabelecer uma relação justa entre uma
organização e têm funcionários com
cargos definidos funções e várias
famílias que não formam um conjunto que
não se conversam entre si
eu tenho um colega professor da usp
acredita assim as famílias é os pais né
as crianças que frequentam a escola são
uma multidão desgovernada por isso que
não dá certo reunião escola e família
porque a escola sabe o que pensa de
maneira coletiva
e as famílias não sabem o que pensa de
então uma relação de poder e uma relação
e justa né porque a escola tem muito
mais poder do que cada família sozinha
como é essa relação poderia ser
solidária
se todos pensassem na educação e na
formação dessa criança que para alguns é
aluno e para outros é filho mas o aluno
é diferente do filho ea gente não
consegue ser solidário que a gente fica
brigando meu filho não faz isso é a
escola fala meu aluno faz
e aí eles ficam perdidos nessa discussão
e eles ficam brigando adulto com o
adulto ea gente acaba esquecendo de novo
né que existe uma pessoa mais jovem mais
nova aí que poderia ganhar tem muito a
acrescentar
se nós conseguíssemos ser solidários né
pensando na parte dele e como é que essa
relação poderia ser é democrática
não vou respeitosa primeiro respeitosa
se há um lugar uma parceria uma reunião
e que não há quase nenhum respeito
é nessa reunião de escola com famílias e
quando eu digo respeito gente não digo
falta de etiqueta não é digno respeito
pelo papel social exercido ou pelas
pessoas que trabalham na escola ou pelas
pessoas que são integrantes da família o
que a gente ouve hoje inclusive embasada
por algumas teorias é que a criança
precisa de uma família assim assim e
assado
enquanto a família não é desse jeito é
quase natural
vejo que é naturalizado que eu não
consiga produzir bem na escola e quando
já se encontra com essas crianças tudo
que a gente sabe fazer reclamada a
família dela julgar essa família e pouca
gente faz e quem sabe ajudar
a mídia que não está dando conta né da
sua tarefa
há famílias que não dão conta da sua
tarefa adultos que não dão conta da vida
adulta né
são absolutamente infantilizados ea
falta de respeito também é da parte da
família né que quando a escola dizem se
uma determinada regra a família design
mas eu pago essa escola porque têm que
obedecer essa regra e por aí vai
desculpe
finalmente como é que essa relação
poderia ser democrática
se houvesse diálogo
quem aqui já foi numa reunião de escola
com pais de alunos sabe que nessa
reunião de democrático não há nada
a escola faz a pauta os pais querem
levantar questões ea escola diz não está
na pauta mas isso é assunto pra gente
conversar você marca o horário e vem
aqui
essa é a maneira que a instituição
escolar têm de fazer frente à sua
incapacidade de lidar com esse problema
que ela não sabe ou não sabe dialogar
ela não sabe ceder espaço para aquilo
que os pais pensam a respeito de uma boa
educação mas pra isso também os pais
deveriam as famílias né
deveriam dar um passo um passo grande
sai de cima do tapete
eu fui orientada não sai muito né mas a
gente deveria sair de cima desse tapete
que nos oferece segurança e um lugar
segundo lugar certo pra gente parar de
pensar no filho e pensar no coletivo
hoje a educação se transformou um bem
que vai produzir ou não um bom futuro
pessoal para cada um de nós a educação
direito que pode transformar para melhor
o contexto em que eu vivo mundo e é isso
que os pais deveriam lo
levar para a escola eu quero que o mundo
seja melhor pra isso nós precisamos de
pessoas com tais virtudes conteúdo eu
fico aflita com essa palavra porque
conteúdo não é conhecimento é os nossos
alunos aprendi um monte de conteúdo e
olha se 10% de tudo o que eles aprendem
se transformar conhecimento está ótimo
mas eu acho que nenhum chega esse índice
conhecimento é complexidade e conteúdo a
quantidade é só pegando um tema e
aprofundando aprofundando aprofundando
que a gente vai levar as crianças a
entenderem o que a metodologia
científica o que é o conhecimento a
sistematizado e por aí vai né e quando a
gente acompanha uma criança um jovem
desse pensamento num tema
aí a gente pode ter certeza que ela vai
precisar cada vez menos e nós pra fazer
isso com outros temas a relação escola
família é uma relação extremamente
delicada muito maltratado aqui em nosso
país muito cheio de certezas
nós precisamos fazer perguntas a
respeito dessa relação essa relação é
boa mesmo para os alunos
o e boa para a escola e para as famílias
quando a gente pensa a educação a gente
tem que pensar sempre na no objetivo
principal da educação que seus mais
novos que às vezes são crianças às vezes
são adolescentes
a gente precisa perguntar a lei nessa
que é boa mesmo e como pode ser esta
relação
existem exemplos dessa relação no brasil
existem existem alguns exemplos
maravilhosos que foram construídos sem
nenhuma intenção e eu me lembro de um
exemplo em especial que vou contar pra
vocês
quero uma favela uma escola no meio de
uma favela na escola pública
em são paulo e você imagina né como é
difícil levar essa escola mas o diretor
é um diretor assim que ele quer que essa
escola vá em frente que é que esses
alunos têm uma boa educação
ele recebeu um determinado dia lá é
muito equipamento de informática recebeu
ficou feliz no dia seguinte foi lá
equipamento tinha sido roubado todo ele
não teve dúvidas
ele alugou um caminhonete com o megafone
saiu pela favela
o seu filho foi roubado o seu filho foi
roubado e ele conseguiu a partir daí
fazer com que a comunidade e enxergar
essa escola de outra maneira não importa
o equipamento da escola importa o meu
filho educação do meu filho ea
comunidade né
dez dessas crianças forem entrando nas
escolas foram conversando
a partir daí criaram coisas maravilhosas
como um quarto dos sonhos onde os pais
colocam por escrito no weiss onde eles
colocam seu sonho na educação dos filhos
e por aí vai né nós temos exemplos
interessantes mas o mais interessante
para o século 21 é não há uma receita e
não é preciso que seja assim ou assado
é preciso que seja uma relação justa
respeitosa democrática e solidária
isso vai acontecer de um jeito aqui em
curitiba de outro jeito em são paulo de
outro jeito no interior paulistano de
outro jeito em goiás de um jeito da
favela e não importa se é escola de
capital público ou privado
o que a gente precisa fazer dialogar
dialogar significa conflitar eu vou
finalizar lembrando de vocês eu adoro
fazer coleção de de ditados populares
vocês conhecem o que diz assim é
conversando que a gente se entende
pois é não é verdade
é conversando que a gente se desentende
porque eu coloco meu ponto de vista você
coloca o seu e daí eles não são muito
assim compatíveis
é esse o nosso medo mas é conversando
que a gente se desentende conflito e
produz e eu acho que esse é o nosso
caminho na relação entre a família dos
alunos e as escolas prazer falar com
vocês briga